anti-transgender bills are sweeping the
country right Wingers are obsessed this
is what they call a culture War we call
it a campaign of persecution and a move
in the continued authoritarian direction
that these right-wingers have gone in
for some time but it is
anti-transgender sentiment that is now
fueling much of what we are seeing among
cultural right-wingers I don't even want
to call them cultural conservatives
cultural conservatism might be like oh I
don't know my wife makes dinner four out
of seven weeks uh four out of seven days
of the week or whatever like this is not
cultural conservatism this is something
very very different and vice has a
report on new data released by the trans
legislation tracker there are it's
February there are already twice as many
anti-trans bills making their way
through State legislatures as what we
saw in 2022
and in fact this legislative session
that started on January 1st this
calendar year of legislation has seen
more than 350 anti-trans bills
introduced in 36 States compared with
170 in all of 2022. we are six weeks
into the year so last year was a
record-breaking year and this year is
already doubling it and only 6 out of 52
weeks through the year anti-trans bills
are being proposed at the state level we
are seeing them at the national level we
are seeing municipalities push this
stuff and this includes everything from
proposed legislation in Wyoming which
would equate gender affirming care to
child abuse despite the fact that every
serious medical Authority has said oh no
no gender affirming care is good
it improves outcomes and well-being
um we have seen bills that just try to
narrow and codify biological definitions
for man and woman and so far three
different states we've seen this in
Tennessee we see it in South Dakota we
we see it in Utah have already passed
bans on gender affirming care the South
Dakota bill that was passed into law has
an element in it which can force trans
youth to detransition at least as far as
the state is concerned in Oklahoma
there's a proposal for a bill which
would ban gender affirming care if
you're under 26 there was a bill
attempted in North Dakota but it failed
which would fine teachers if they use
the pronouns preferred by the trans
person trans person says you know I go
by she even though I was born
biologically male teacher says okay
I'll do that teacher can get fined based
on the bill that fortunately failed in
North Dakota
so this is a very serious issue and this
is a serious issue even if you are
someone in my audience and I know that
there are some of you who aren't yet
really totally sure where you land on
all aspects of what's going on in the
trans community and let me tell you you
can say as I do we still got to figure
out when it comes to some sports when
we're talking about uh trans women
really right because remember even the
sports issue you've got all trans issues
and then within that you have issues
related to sports and then within that
you have issues related to trans women
in sports and then within that it's only
some sports
nobody's getting all shaken up about oh
you know what uh there there's a trans
woman who wants to play with the women
in chess I've not heard anybody bring
that issue up it's some sports only
trans women okay so this is a very very
narrow issue you can take the position
that you're not yet sure how that should
be dealt with
that's totally fine while still
recognizing that the 99 of all of this
legislation that's being proposed is
dangerous and it's the new scapegoat as
we talked about you know I did an
interview
for some of our other platforms with a
drag performer earlier this week which
we're going to be publishing for you
soon and in that interview we talk about
how the tropes have shifted from many of
the ones used against gay men 15 or so
years ago when I started interviewing
some of the homophobes they've shifted a
lot of the same stuff over uh to trans
people and it's oh you know a sexual
assault and pedophilia bathrooms you got
to be worried about the bathrooms this
is just shifting the hate to Target
trans people and their families and one
of the things that we're seeing
and it's horrible that this is happening
is in some states Texas Alabama Arkansas
we are seeing families with trans kids
moving moving out moving out of the
states all together and
um this is potentially going to go in a
very very dark Direction and one of the
reasons that these bills uh are
dangerous is that they really push the
boundaries of demonizing trans people by
codifying that this is a group that's a
problem we need to pass special laws
because this group is so problematic and
this is going to expand and we know it's
going to expand because it is expanding
it used to be just about bathrooms now
it's about what are teachers allowed to
say if they don't want to get fined it's
about so many things beyond that so I'm
putting it on your radar this is all to
fix problems that really don't exist
the issue of oh
people will pretend to be trans to go
into bathrooms to spy on people in
stalls of it's not happening it's not
happening and that's against the law no
matter what your uh agenda identity is
and it is not an issue it just doesn't
exist and then lastly this anti-trans
group it's not a group in the collective
anti-trans movement
um also wants many of us to believe that
gender affirming care is harmful but
there's extensive research from medical
governing bodies the American Medical
Association American Psychological
American Psychiatric association
American Academy of Pediatrics they have
endorsed gender affirming care even for
minors when you go through the correct
protocol now the right will say they're
chopping off the breasts of prepubescent
women
well they're not women and they don't
have breasts if they're prepubescent and
it's really not happening and when push
comes to shove they really struggle to
present any data that suggests that this
is an epidemic but it doesn't matter
it's about what can you trick people
into believing so we're going to follow
it extraordinarily closely and it is
just as scary as it sounds not exactly
small government
Nikki Haley crumbles like a pumice stone
is that a good analogy I don't know
metaphor
um she was asked three times by Fox News
propagandist Sean Hannity can you tell
me how you differ with Donald Trump on
policy and she was either unable to or
unwilling to do that this is amazing to
see let's get right into it I told you
based on her campaign launch video on um
Tuesday
that Nikki Haley seems to be making the
argument I'm like Trump but younger and
a woman which by the way is identity
politics which we'll talk about later
but it really seems like she's unwilling
or unable to draw any policy
distinctions let's take a look at this
if you had to delineate where say you
and president Trump differ yeah on
issues where would you start
well first let's say in reference to
Whoopi
um you know the thought of me getting
into the race makes the Liberals heads
explode and so I welcome it because it
shows we're doing something right well
but you're not needing to convince any
liberals right now you actually need to
convince Republican voters because
you're in a primary Nikki you know when
it comes to what we're looking at now
listen to the first 20 minutes of your
show look at everything that's wrong in
this country and tell me we don't need
new leadership but the difference is we
need new generational leadership okay so
that's so far all we have is we need a
different generation of people Trump 76
Nikki Haley is I don't know at least 25
years younger than that I would guess
and so so so far the argument is we just
need someone younger we have to leave
the status quo we have to leave this
chaos behind and we've got to start
talking about the future you need a
Washington Outsider that's going to come
in and say it's yes I understand that
families are having to pay more to make
their grocery bill I understand that
they are worried about out their
children who may never get back from
what they lost during covet I understand
the fact that when someone's Factory
leaves town he's worried that his future
went with it so this is verbatim stuff
Trump says so far not a single policy
difference I understand that you should
not have Americans looking up at the sky
and seeing a Chinese spy balloon looking
back at them this is insanity and what
we need remember she's running against
Trump right now not Joe Biden or a lot
of changes first of all we've got too
many politicians in D.C that are past
their Prime we have to have terms so
again just there's too many old people
that's in Congress we need to see
competency tests for any elected
official over the age of 75. we'll get
back to that by the way that's
interesting we've got to stop the
spending addiction that is happening
that is causing inflation to go up and
we need to start realizing that we don't
need our politicians getting on TV and
talking we need the people in DC doing
and we need to spark a fire up under
them and that's what I'm willing to do
and if you are tired of losing because
we've lost the last seven out of eight
popular votes for president we're doing
something wrong if you're tired of
losing then join me I I know you all
notice this but there is not a single
policy difference cited there with
Donald Trump
um this continued Sean Hannity tried it
again
let me go back to my original question
though because yeah which you didn't
answer by the way anybody that is
looking or seeking a nomination it's
you're going to be comparing and
contrasting your policy positions your
views what direction you want to take
the country with your competitors uh
right now there's there's former
president Trump is the only other
candidate for the nomination we expect
many others maybe even Mike Pompeo was
on earlier in the program today where do
you see if you see policy differences
beyond what you mentioned which are
generational differences was what
specific policy areas would you would
you say part with Donald Trump now by
the way good job by Sean Hannity right
well good job because Hannity's already
decided he supports Trump it's Trump's
friend so he's actually doing like what
we might call a real interview
what I am saying is I don't kick
sideways I'm kicking forward Joe Biden
is the president he's the one I'm
running against okay that's code for I'm
not going to criticize Republicans I'm
going to criticize Joe Biden she's not
running against Joe Biden in order to
win against Joe Biden she has to defeat
Trump and what I'm saying is you don't
have to be 80 years old to be president
we don't need to have these same people
going back again we need something new
we need a new generation of Fighters we
need people that understand whether the
American your average American is coming
from and we shouldn't be afraid to fight
for that and that's what I'm willing to
do I'm not going to kick sideways I
don't okay I'm not going to kick
sideways she's not going to criticize
other people that she is running against
and who she has to argue she is a better
choice then that's going to be very
tough to win then now as interesting as
this is
their voters don't care about policy so
it might not you know they sort of are
having the last laugh in the sense that
we look at this and we go she's not
articulating a single policy difference
to Trump I don't know that she has to to
win a republican nomination that's the
sort of sad thing she maybe just does
have to say the stuff that she's saying
I don't know Hannity tried once more I
want to take the country with your
competitors uh right now there's there's
former president Trump is the only other
candidate for the nomination we expect
many others maybe even Mike Pompeo okay
and so I'm realizing that that's the
clip we actually already looked at okay
so multiple attempts there and she
doesn't draw any policy distinctions
this was obvious from the campaign
launch video The Campaign launch video
contained no policy distinctions and
just her saying it's time for a new
generation this is apparently what she's
going to run on plus identity politics
which we will talk about a little bit
later on these clips if you want to
check them out are found on our YouTube
channel youtube.com the davidpackman
show and also the David Pacman Show Now
in Spanish you can find the Spanish
YouTube channel at davidpackman.com
Spanish
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
let's talk a little bit more about just
a wacky First 48 Hours of 2024
presidential campaign for former
ambassador to the United Nations former
South Carolina Governor Nikki Haley
really a very bad first couple of days
day one of her campaign videos surface
wherein Nikki Haley defends the
Confederate flag and wrongly claims that
states can just choose to secede from
the United States day two which was
yesterday Nikki Haley holds her first
campaign event and plays the exact same
type of identity politics that
Republicans claim to be against I'm a
woman I'm a minority I thought
Republicans told us identity politics is
bad or is it only bad when the left does
it here she invokes her own
uniqueness racially to claim the
country's not racist which is a really
popular line among Republicans in doing
so not only does she play identity
politics she kind of seems to prove the
country might be racist take a listen to
this Joe and kamla even say America's
racist
nothing could be further from the truth
okay
[Applause]
the American people know better
my immigrant parents know better
and take it from me the first minority
female governor in history America is
not a racist country
you know I'm not sure first of all overt
identity politics just the the exact
type of identity politics that they
attack all the time let's put the
hypocrisy aside for a second hypocrisy
knows no bounds at this point with these
people
I don't know that when you say
we elected the first minority woman
governor in 2011 that it's the strongest
evidence that the U.S at least wasn't a
racist country it seems like a little
bit late in the game to be able to make
that case by the time that the country
was hundreds of years old we finally
elected the first minority female
governor which proves there's no race
problem in the United States or gender
problem no woman president ever
first woman VP not until 2020. these are
not particularly compelling data points
to be perfectly honest with you Nikki
Haley continuing to play the same
identity politics that she says is bad
when other people do it saying May the
best woman win I will simply say this
May the best woman win
pretty clever line huh guys
the crowd not exactly reflecting and
saying wait a second I thought we were
supposed to be against that type of
identity Paul no the crowd simply cheers
um one other interesting note she kicked
off this event with a prayer from
extremist Pastor John Hagee I'm not even
going to waste your time with a clip but
I will briefly mention that John Hagee
runs the Cornerstone Church in San
Antonio Texas extremist lunatic long
history of saying crazy stuff he said
Hitler was sent by God to usher in the
state of Israel he said Hitler was a
half-breed Jew he called the Catholic
Church the great he has said
insane things about abortion and 9 11
all these crazy things and Nikki Haley
started this off by saying I still want
to be Pastor Hagee when I grow up before
I start I've got to give a shout out to
the people who took the podium by the
way plagued with audio issues the entire
event
um to Pastor Hagee I still say I want to
be you when I grow up thank you
well and very very muted clapping at
that moment everything about this event
was pathetic humiliating and
hypocritical but there was one really
funny moment from this event which I
want to actually devote a little bit of
time to during yesterday's pathetic
campaign launch rally for Nikki Haley's
2024 Republican primary run
she did say one thing that's really
funny which is she demanded a cognitive
test for any candidate that's over 75
years old it just so happens that Donald
Trump is 76 years old now I I think
she's only talking about this overtly
when it comes to Joe Biden but it's a
pretty interesting way to also draw a
distinction with the guy she's running
against in the primary take a listen to
this
[Applause]
well and mandatory mental competency
tests for politicians over 75 years old
now I love this because
obviously the big meaning of it is Joe
Biden is 80 and the Wright loves to talk
about that and one of the main arguments
that Nikki Haley is making in this just
nascent
primary campaign is that she's younger
that she is from a different generation
but we all of course know that Trump's
brain has glitched very badly over the
last six years and there are real
questions about Trump and cognitive
tests as well and Trump would also be
subject to one so I believe that
although the
of official meaning of this cognitive
test thing is a signal about Biden you
all know that Nikki Haley is also using
it to talk about Trump I don't know
whether the people in her audience
realize that which makes it particularly
funny now it the fact remains that she
can talk about cognitive tests all she
wants and whether 80 year old Biden or
76 year old Trump who would be 82 and 78
at the time of the next uh inauguration
I think roughly
um she can talk about that all she wants
she's still drawn absolutely no policy
distinction from Donald Trump and in
order to face Joe Biden she first needs
to win the Republican primary and at
this point in time it's not clear what
her argument is for why anybody should
vote for her other than I'm younger than
Trump maybe that resonates with the
Republican party at this point I don't
know it's going to be a real question my
guess is that by Monday maybe by Tuesday
we will have some polling in the
Republican primary that is from after
Nikki Haley's announcement she went in
polling three percent as a non-candidate
we'll see where she ends up Monday
Tuesday speaking of non-candidates Ron
DeSantis from Florida we know that he's
adopted a lot of Donald Trump's
mannerisms in speaking including this
accordion hands thing that Donald Trump
does very often he also now seems to be
copying how Donald Trump says China this
is like really really weird China yeah
um there's a video that was much
publicized yesterday
of Ron DeSantis taking questions at a
um digital Bill of Rights event and he
seems to be copying Trump's
pronunciation of China take a listen to
this
so that's that's there you also have the
role of China
oh what a weird what a weird uh Society
we're in huh let's let's take it from
the top so that's that's there you also
have the role of China in Tech uh with
things like like Tick Tock and this is
something there if you look at the tick
tock that they use in China China it's
much different than what they're trying
to do in the United States with China
it's all China by the way it's really
funny hearing scientists talk about
technology Sanders talk about technology
and foreign policy he sounds genuinely
clueless a very uh wholesome patriotic
uh in the United States they're trying
to inject as much garbage into this as
possible yeah isn't that bizarre like
this is not the biggest issue but it is
very strange very very strange and Trump
has a long history of uh saying China in
a really odd way let's say China China
China China China China China China
[Music]
[Applause]
you go over to China China China China
China China China China
so anyway I'm thinking that this might
be really funny until we realize it kind
of isn't and the world is crumbling
again but for the time being
this is an insane Republican primary it
hasn't even really started and it's
crazy Donald Trump already attacking Ron
DeSantis slash meatball Ron going after
Nikki Haley in new ways which we we will
talk about a little bit later uh we have
Ron DeSantis mirroring Trump but not yet
announcing even though he's leading
Trump in some polls while not being a
candidate Nikki Haley announces early
she's only running against Trump right
now and yet she can draw not a single
distinction between herself and Donald
Trump it's February not of 2024 of 2023
so this is going to be a Bonkers primary
and if nothing else I'm glad you'll all
be here with me to observe it all uh we
will have these clips that I played for
you
on our Instagram you can find that by
searching Instagram for David packman
show we're going to take a very quick
break Neil Valley will join me after the
break maybe not a name you know but a
guest requested by many of our viewers
and listeners it will be a fascinating
conversation and then we'll be back with
more of the events of the last 24 hours
we'll listen to a voicemail or two much
taking place today on the show glad
you're with us
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to be joined on the program today by
Neil Valley who's a lecturer in
sociology and Rutherford Foundation
research fellow at the University of
otago New Zealand I hope otago is the
right pronunciation Neil uh the the
latest book is futilitarianism
neoliberalism and the production of
uselessness I really appreciate your
time today
uh thanks David thanks for having me so
maybe to start with
futilitarianism I think many of us could
Intuit we're talking about there is
something futile about the way we've
organized much of our economies and and
the world and society and culture but
what what did you what do you mean by
the term
uh yeah so by the term it really came to
me as in the process of writing the book
um the book initially started out of a
series of uh protests against
um cuts the humanities division at my
University and I originally started
thinking about
um it was really like the the kind of
futility the uselessness of the
humanities within the kind of
contemporary University structure the
way that it's constructed is useless but
if you do Humanities or Arts you can get
a job so on and so forth but then I
started the more I looked into that the
more I started to realize that this idea
of the assessment of utility
kind of spread out much further into
kind of everyday life in the 21st
century
um and so where I got to a
futilitarianism basically is
as many of
um many many people might have heard the
word utilitarianism
and on a very basic level utilitarianism
is
that you maximize utility for a degree
that's good or the greatest number
essentially so each individual
um every decision they make they
maximize their own utility
and this should lead to a kind of
majority happiness yeah and basically my
argument utilitarianism is that we got
to a point now where each individual is
trying to maximize their utility that
might be by getting an education and
getting further training you know um
getting into debt to start a business or
so on and so forth but in doing so it
actually leads to the greatest
unhappiness or the greatest number
because we're entirely individualized
atomized so it's a kind of inversion of
the utilitarian code
um and this is the state that I feel
like we know I live in but the more we
maximize utility the more it leads to
the to kind of deconstruction of of the
common common good
there's an inevitable sort of interplay
here between the concept of
utilitarianism the capitalist systems
that to differing degrees most uh uh
modern what we might call Western
countries although the term Western is
maybe not the the right one
neo-liberalism as well it's hard to get
out of including the sort of media
culture and the way in which
most people are learning about the world
so to speak all of these things seem
completely interrelated and maybe one of
the things that has changed or maybe has
become evident is that the preferences
and path that one increasingly takes is
less self-directed than we might imagine
and really more prescribed by all of
those other systems that I mentioned
yeah that's a really interesting point
actually and it's the kind of one of the
great kind of contradictions of the kind
of neoliberal period is that everything
is about you know personal
responsibility
um self-care
um picking yourself up by the foot
straps and making the most of your own
life and yeah as you make the point as
that actually these decisions that we're
making supposedly as kind of free uh
individuals are actually prescribed to
us that there's a certain structure in
place that forces us towards certain
decisions so for instance as a small
example I talked about the University at
the start there
um is that the way that universities are
constructed particularly across the you
know the global North is
is towards kind of getting a degree that
can get you a job
so if that's kind of rhetoric that comes
out from you know kind of public
discourse from media and so on and so
forth most most individuals that in
looking at University through that land
so they make decisions on what they
study based on
um you know can I get a job at the end
of this that seems on the surfacing an
individual decision right and yet it's
entirely prescribed within this kind of
structure
um and I think this is an effect of
neoliberalism and I think more recent
studies of neoliberalism have started to
tease us out and initial studies of
neoliberalism are often about the kind
of um uh you know that it was all about
the kind of free market the rollback of
the states
um individuals who are kind of free to
whatever they wanted free to operate
highly liked in the market but more and
more we've come to realize there's some
brilliant studies of neoliberalism is
that actually neoliberalism isn't about
to roll back as a state it's about a
very different form of State
intervention and the role as a state has
become to encase the market to protect
the market from democratic decision
making and the early neoliberal thinkers
often talked about this
um at the Walter lipmann colloquium in
1938 where it was kind of first big
meeting of the neoliberal intellectuals
in Europe
um and they talked about the liberal
thinkers of the 19th century
um as opposed to a kind of new a new
liberalism and neoliberalism and for the
19th century left a fair kind of free
market liberals they used the analogy of
a road
um and they said if if there are no
rules on the road essentially people
will just keep driving into each other
they'll crash and so on and so forth so
what they they saw neoliberalism as a
kind of Highway code almost that you set
the rules of the roads and people can
drive when people are driving they're
driving to where they want to go they're
seemingly making individualized
decisions but there's just over
um arching structure that guides the way
that they drive and that's how they
envisage the market economy in the near
Liberal Society it's not everyone go for
their life do whatever you want it's a
there's this overall structure that
guides people in a certain way but
people still feel like they're making
individualized decisions but it's
actually Guided by a certain method a
certain structure
when in the book you write about the
useless and repetitive behaviors that
can become a trap of neoliberalism
absent any context what I would imagine
there would be one sort of story that
fits that is you go to school to get the
job and then you take out debt to get
the car in the house and the credit card
and you get a slight raise so you take
on a little bit more debt and it's sort
of like this endless rinse repeat and by
the way you're you're basically buying
the stuff that media messages tell you
you want or you should want or whatever
the case may be is that one of the
mechanisms that you're talking about and
what else did you mean by it
yeah very much so so that's certainly a
good example um and I you know I work
with with lots of students
um who are kind of increasingly
wondering what is the point of what I'm
doing here you know they look at their
for instance their parents generation
and we might have gone to University
particularly say here in New Zealand
they would have gone to University
um for free and also would have been
given us you know a scholarship so they
would have been paid essentially to go
to university and now these these
students are coming out they're paying
massive fees to go to universities
they're all getting into debt to do so
and then they come out the other end in
that to a kind of depleted job market
where a house the house market is
absolutely crazy you know in New
Zealand's the average cost of house at
the moment is a million dollars so you
know kids coming up with that much stats
are not gonna be able to afford to buy
houses so there's this kind of sense
that all the things that we're supposed
to do all the things that we've been
kind of have told well will lead to a
kind of good future for us are suddenly
crumbling you know you if you go to
university and get a degree you're
supposed to come out and get a steady
job and be able to kind of live you know
be able to get a house be able to do all
the things that we associate you know in
the kind of Western or Global
um the global North as kind of
a a a good life suddenly none of these
things are available and so many people
are in debt and they're getting more
debt and so on and so forth and it's
this kind of endless cycle and yet we're
completely trapped and doing the same
things over and over again there are no
no way it seems like there's very little
few ways to get out of of that trap of
thinking this is what I have to do I
have to go to university or I have to
get through further training I have to
do so on and so forth to live this good
life in the future and the more we do it
the more things like our Collective
economic and social conditions get worse
and that's the tract I call in the book
this utilitarian condition we get stuck
in this kind of endless trap and there
really aren't I mean genuinely there
aren't that many ways to completely get
out of that right I mean when we think
about them there's there's the idea of
the total off-grid life where you
essentially leaves leave modern society
as the case may be you have to figure
out a way to meet your basic needs and
to really do that without touching the
standard kind of corners of the economy
that you're talking about it's
extraordinarily difficult another one
would be well you do it in a hyper
driveway for a short period of time such
that you make enough money that then you
could exit in a sort of different way
yeah I I don't I mean it's it's
genuinely quite difficult to not be part
of it at all
yeah yeah very much so and and you know
in the in the introduction to the book I
make a distinction
um between futility and annihilism and I
think
they're like they're the the example you
used of you know going off grids and so
on and so forth It's a sense that you're
right like there are a few options the
only options we have are to try and
escape from it a very few people can
yeah you might be able to move off grids
but then you're kind of outside of
society yes level you can't you can't
influence you can't
um shape the way the world runs you just
and that to me is a form of kind of
almost like a passive nihilism it's like
I'm accepting that this world that we
constructed is meaningless and I'm gonna
sit outside of it yes and then there's
more kind of active forms of nihilism
though like example you use is that you
you go hard you you try and invent
something you do and so forth but even
even entrepreneurs I guess like the kind
of Silicon Valley entrepreneurs are are
trying to exit from contemporary
capitalism they're trying to get beyond
the kind of mundane kind of existence
that Mo like the majority of people have
to have to live in so there's two forms
of exit there but those exits don't
actually do anything about changing the
kind of fundamentals of that society
that we're mostly stuck in and the
reality is for the vast majority of us
no matter what kind of situation when we
have to we only have the kind of
structures of society that are available
to us and we have to somehow make the
best of that and it seems like that's
getting harder and harder and harder and
there is of course a kind of
generational politics in that you know
we're increasingly we're seeing that a
kind of new class politics emerge in the
21st century or basically people that
own property and particularly housing
and people that don't and that often
Falls in generational lines and for a
younger and this book often I I do say
in the introduction of this book is a
kind of is a kind of Requiem for a sort
of doomed youth in many ways it it for
it's for a kind of younger generation of
the world that they're emerging into
and so it seems that there's the
question of how individuals can choose a
different path but then there's another
question of how can Society be changed
such that the default path is what
changes and it seems I mean are there
any actions that can accomplish both or
is it really you have to decide I'm
going to be within it completely but try
to change it or I will try to exit
personally
yeah I I feel like the former is our
only real option and and so I make a
kind of a a call in the book but we need
we need to turn essentially to one
another that actually
especially on the last you know
post 1989 poster fall of the Soviet
Union that I that the kind of there's
been a kind of and and inherent sort of
distrust in the left of collectiveness
of collectivity
um I think particularly probably up
until the 2008 crisis and I think since
then we've seen the return of you know
particularly in the US or in the UK
parts of Europe of kind of democratic
socialism
the idea of of a kind of collective
subject of a collective political
subject
um and then in the conclusion of the
book I I construct a kind of I guess
it's a theoretical idea of this
collector subject and I call it the
futilitarian and it's oh it's it's a
kind of rest for uh um a development of
the prokaryote so the precarious is
obviously a kind of describes a whole
group of people who exist in kind of
precarious lives whether or not they're
working conditions or even just their
living conditions
and there's also these people aren't you
know like the traditional idea of a
union which I think is also extremely
important and there is obviously a
Resurgence of a union there's something
you know people that work in the same
conditions and they share the same lives
in many ways certainly the same working
life the precarious actually a more
disparate Collective subject it can be
people working in Uber drivers but can
also include you know casual lectures at
University people who who don't who are
living in kind of precarious conditions
and for me the futilitarian is like an
extension of that it includes the people
who live in precarious lives are a
precarious situations
but also so many of us who actually on
the surface looked like we're in quite
secure conditions still experience this
deep sense of futility in what we're
doing and I feel like actually this
shared experience of futility across
different scopes of social life can
actually be the things that can that if
we recognize it in one another we can
use it as a way to to build a kind of
political a collective political subject
that can actually confront
um the kind of the way the world works
if if if we accept if we'd see
um our if we see fertility in one
another and we go actually I experience
this form of futility and of course some
people experience much more extreme
forms of utility than others in the same
way that some people experience much
more extreme forms of precariousness but
that doesn't necessarily mean we can't
somehow recognize it in one another and
try and realize and I think part of the
problem with contemporary capitalism and
particularly its neoliberal mutation is
that we're we're expected to see
everything
as a reflection of our failures
essentially so anything that doesn't
work anything we end up in debt we we
can't get a job so it's because we we in
some way are brokenly somehow I haven't
um haven't done the right thing
and what I really want what I'm kind of
pleading really in the book is to see
that actually these experiences of
futility are not personal defects
they're a completely logical
um experiences of the kind of capsular
system in which in which we live today
the book is fascinating and slightly
depressing but only in the way that gets
you to really think about things uh the
book is futilitarianism neoliberalism
and the production of uselessness we've
been speaking with the book's author
Neil Valley lecturer in sociology and
Rutherford Foundation research fellow at
the University of otago New Zealand
really appreciate your time and your
insights today
well thanks so much David
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
so almost immediately after Nikki
Haley's announcement that she's running
for president through the Republican
nomination in 2024 the Trump campaign
put out a confusing and bizarre campaign
email attacking Nikki Haley and what's
really fascinating about this email
which we'll look at in a moment is it
attacks Nikki Haley for being too much
of a leftist but also for being too
extreme on the right it is as confusing
as and bizarre as everything we have
come to expect and see from the Trump
campaign take a look at this so the
first lines are for so it's called the
real Nikki Haley first of all Trump's
going to tell you who the real Nikki
Haley is okay it starts by saying
Hillary Clinton is an inspiration to
Nikki Haley in a 2012 interview with the
New York Times Nikki Haley said the
reason I actually ran for office is
because of Hillary Clinton so here it
wants to tag Nikki Haley it wants to
trash Nikki Haley by saying she's really
not a conservative because she was
inspired by Hillary Clinton of course it
ignores the uncontroversial reality that
you could disagree with Hillary
Clinton's politics but see Hillary
Clinton's success as an elected official
and public servant as someone who is a
woman as inspirational that's not super
controversial but she's not really on
the right she's on the left because she
was inspired by Hillary and then in the
next sentence Trump slams Nikki Haley
for supporting Paul Ryan's plan for
entitlement reform which threatened
Medicare and Social Security
saying quote Haley praised Ryan's
Medicare proposal at the time and said
lawmakers should examine Medicare and
Social Security spending to address
federal debt then quoting Nikki Haley
herself from 2010 saying what they need
to be doing is looking at entitlements
look at Social Security look at Medicaid
look at Medicare look at these things
let's go to the heart of what is causing
government to grow and tackle that
they're playing that Nikki Haley is too
extreme in what she wants to cut
and in the government spending she wants
to reduce which is normally an attack
that the left makes on the right so
Haley's a leftist and Haley is too far
right it's not coherent but in the
defense of trump Haley's campaign isn't
very coherent so far and Trump's attacks
on her are also not coherent but Nikki
Haley at some point might want to
articulate what policy is she actually
running on now I say she might want to
articulate it because as I said earlier
in the program it's not clear that she
needs any policy in order to win a
Republican primary Trump had some policy
statements in 2016. most of them we all
knew were never going to be achieved he
wasn't going to replace Obamacare and he
wasn't going to build a wall that Mexico
was going to pay for and he wasn't going
to do all the things he claimed it
didn't really matter it's not clear that
these Republicans care about policy
enough to hold it against Nikki Haley
but at a certain point you'll have to
come up with something that at least she
can put on her website and that hasn't
happened yet it's all incoherent and
this is exactly what I would expect much
more of in this Republican primary
continuing his attack on Nikki Haley I
now want to uh highlight for you
a truly hilarious and also completely
unbelievable and kind of self-owning
statement that Donald Trump made about
Nikki Haley so let me back it up Nikki
Haley worked for Donald Trump's
Administration and what I mean by that
is Donald Trump made Nikki Haley
ambassador to the United Nations for the
United States and Trump has a long
history of saying I hire the best people
that I that's one of the things I do I
hire the absolute best people it was a
joke Trump hired some of the worst
people and regularly had to fire them
and claim that they were actually bad
people and he was somehow duped or they
were good but then became bad or you
know he's had to explain how did you
hire all these bad people fine so one of
the issues here is how is Trump going to
attack Nikki Haley given that Trump was
positive and enough about Nikki Haley to
hire her and make her part of his
administration well Trump's new line
which he is talking about of course on
his platform truth social
is he hired her to be an ambassador
to help the people of South Carolina by
getting her out of South Carolina this
is I mean it's it's truly amazing stuff
Trump posting to truth social quote the
greatest thing Nikki Haley did for our
country and the great state of South
Carolina was accepting the position of
United Nations Ambassador so that the
incredible then Lieutenant Governor
Henry McMaster could be the governor of
South Carolina where he has done an
absolutely fantastic job that was a big
reason why I appointed Nikki to the
position it was a favor to the people I
love in South Carolina this is of course
absurd gaslighting think about what
Trump wants you to believe he thought of
trump was sitting there when he became
president
thinking to himself okay let's see Nikki
Haley's a terrible governor I want to
help the people of South Carolina so the
way I'm going to help the people of
South Carolina is I'm going to make
Nikki Haley Ambassador even though she's
a terrible elected official
just to get her out of South Carolina
in order
to help that state by making Henry
McMaster the governor this is idiocy
nobody would believe that this is what
Donald Trump did but the real story here
is it's only February of the year before
the election it's not February 2024 and
it's getting this insane it's February
2023 and it's already completely Bonkers
and insane this is going to get way
crazier and just wait until more people
get into this race there is a very sick
woman in Arizona now not Kerry Lake not
Kerry Lake I'm talking about state
senator Wendy Rogers State Senator Wendy
Rogers 48 hours ago said Kerry Lake
might still be instated the governor of
Arizona now I want you to answer
honestly really tell me
do you believe Wendy Rogers believes any
of what she's saying or does she have to
keep saying this stuff because she
started saying it and it would be
embarrassing to her to have to admit
that she was wrong take a listen to what
she had to say remember Carrie Lake ran
for governor in Arizona she lost in that
her opponent Katie Hobbs got more votes
Katie Hobbs is now the governor of
Arizona even if for whatever reason
Katie Hobbs resigned or died or whatever
uh it would actually be the Secretary of
State of Arizona that becomes Governor
Arizona doesn't currently have a
position lieutenant governor although
they are creating it starting in a
couple of years but here is what Wendy
Rogers said and I get asked this all the
time especially up to you my district on
various rural radio stations Senator
Rogers the the radio stations must be so
rural that the people don't understand
how government works you represent four
other counties
what hope do you have of getting any of
this legislation passed and my answer is
twofold number one I was voted in by 27
percentage points to do the very thing
that I'm doing which is represent my
constituents and make sure that my
voters were not disenfranchised and
number two they weren't
you never know uh everything that will
happen in terms of Kerry Lake being
instated as governor and I get asked
this
yeah also I'm waiting to see if maybe
the Eagles actually won the Super Bowl
on Sunday you never know you know what I
mean in a couple months or maybe in a
year
um it we might learn that it was
actually the Eagles who won which is
really really wild my uh my headphone
has just popped out of my ear and it's
going to be hard to hear the following
clip if I don't put it back in there we
go
um so
do you think she believes this do you
think Wendy Rogers believes this or do
you think it's part of the Griff now
here's a reminder the very same Wendy
Rogers a couple months ago or when was
it December I guess uh December she
claimed that Kerry Lake was the
governor-elect of Arizona she wasn't and
we had the same question then does she
believe this the problem and uh we need
to get to the bottom of all of this and
I just telling you we're not having it
anymore we're done as Kerry said
as Kerry said you're messing with the
wrong people
[Music]
right is Carrie Lake the governor elect
of Arizona yes
is there any doubt in your mind
okay so just so you know there's no
lieutenant governor in Arizona the
secretary of state is next in line if
anything should happen to the governor
death resignation impeachment whatever
starting in 2027 the lieutenant governor
is going to become the would become the
governor upon the death resignation or
removal from Office of the governor of
Arizona and then it would presumably go
to the Secretary of State so who thinks
that Wendy Rogers genuinely believes
at any moment you might see the in
statement of Kerry Lake as governor of
Arizona and who believes that Wendy
Rogers knows she's lying but this is
just the nonsense that she feels she has
to say for whatever reason let me know
in a YouTube comment send an email to
info davidpackman.com send a smoke
signal telegram however you want to get
in touch I'm curious what you think I
genuinely don't know I lean towards
Wendy Rogers knows this isn't true
there's no possibility of instating
Kerry Lake but Maybe I'm Wrong we have a
voicemail number and that number is 2192
David P I don't know what I must have
said to cause this but someone called in
and asked about how I celebrate
Christmas
hi David I know that your um Argentinian
Heritage is very important to you and
you're teaching your daughter
uh Spanish and all about that right
um so I was curious
um what does your holiday tradition look
like is it an Argentinian
Christmas or Hanukkah or a combination
of all those things or more of a
traditional looking American Christmas
um I'm just curious about what it what
it looks like or maybe there's a
specific tradition you Embrace yes I
embrace the tradition of Asian food on
Christmas I am uh I I'm Jewish
so there is no Christmas celebration in
my house my daughter will not be
celebrating Christmas because we aren't
Christian and and we don't celebrate
Christmas so it has nothing to do with
being Argentinian or an American citizen
or any of those different things the
tradition on Christmas is a Jewish
tradition where I believe even though
the default is often Chinese food
I believe Indian food is absolutely fine
on Christmas I've never gone for like
Thai or Cambodian or Vietnamese food on
Christmas but I think it would be fine
it's really whatever's open but
typically it is either Chinese food or
this particular Christmas uh it was
Indian food so that is going to be the
tradition and uh yeah I don't know what
I might have said that would have made
someone think I I celebrate Christmas
but I'm glad to answer questions about
Indian or Chinese food at any time we
have a great bonus show for you today
the sacks the sacks the sex trafficking
saxophone the sex trafficking
investigation into Republican Matt Gates
is being dropped oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad Matt Gates will not be charged we
will talk about it new childhood obesity
guidance is Raising concerns over the
risk of eating disorders and the
Democrat who nearly unseated Lauren
bobert Adam Frisch has announced he is
running against her again in 2024 it
came down to just such a small margin
what can we do to really be sure we
remove bobert in 24 Is it wise for Adam
Frisch to announce his candidacy so
early or not we are going to talk about
all of that on today's bonus show I
would really love for you to become a
member not just because you'll get
access to the bonus show but because we
do depend on members to fund the program
our primary funding source the plurality
of our dollars come from the membership
program you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now and boy has it
started 24 starts now that's 2-4 starts
now all one word to get a discount off
of a membership you'll get access to the
bonus show the commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show invitations to
the members only town halls and access
to the members only soundboard when I
play the clips nuclear collaboration
right
yes that is a freaking Predator right
there that soundboard we make available
to our members so all great benefits to
take advantage of sign up at
joinpakman.com and remember if you have
a parent a friend whatever
who could use some American political
commentary in Spanish the Spanish
YouTube channel has launched it is at
davidpackman.com
Spanish we're working on our first
thousand subscribers there it's an
exciting new project make sure whoever
it is that would prefer to consume this
sort of content in Spanish rather than
English is aware of it davidpackland.com
Spanish I will see you on the bonus
foreign